You must prepare Lissa
for her new role
as head of the Dragomir family.
And Rose?
She'll do her duty.
Is this something that you want?
There are a parade of people
dying to be on the throne.
The only thing separating
this dominion
from that fate is me.
Then go out there, and show
them all what you've got.
And if I've got nothing?
Then I will get you out,
I promise you that.
Guardians are raised
to be tough.
No matter how good you are,
there's good enough
and there's gone.
I want to protect my best friend
from danger.
Good.
You staying out of trouble?
Oh, you know me. I'm
always dancing alongside of it.
There's something
strange happening.
We will survive, because
there is no other option.